[Musique]
bonjour que c'est une pop m wu
vous êtes l'une des porte parole du
nouveau parti anti capitaliste tout
comme olivier besancenot et philippe
poutou christine boutin
selon un sondage doxa dentsu consulting
pour france info et pour le figaro ce
matin six français sur dix sont
mécontents de l'action du gouvernement
et vous surprise ou conforter dans ce
qu'il faudrait penser du président de la
république et de son chef de
gouvernement
ça n'a pas vraiment étonnant puisque en
fait la politique qui mène d une
politique complètement impopulaires pour
en même temps il va très très vite on a
l'impression qui veut tout faire passer
le plus vite possible pendant qu'il a la
main et il a fondu des boutons l'âge de
8 ans non je pense qu'il n'ya pas enfin
je pense qu'il ya pas de fautes je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose d'extrêmement
professionnelle puisque c'est quelqu'un
qui a à gérer sa carrière en chef
d'entreprise qui gère son parti en chef
d'entreprise il a un but c'est de faire
passer une politique pour réformer la
france comme il dit d'accord quand il
est à fait ce pour quoi il a été élu il
avait dit qu'il aurait fait est fait
alors ça exactement il le fait à fond on
sent qu'il veut vraiment changer la
société radicalement sens de forcer
notre migration ça a pas du tout fan de
notre vie ratio pour un adversaire de
place pour sa part apparemment ceux qui
sont les plus satisfaits de l'action du
gouvernement ce serait surtout des
sympathisants de la droite
we say die de son âge alors en même
temps il s'est présenté mais c'est une
vraie arnaque c'est à dire qu'il a fait
sa campagne sur le thème je suis un
homme nouveau alors que c'est quand même
sans doute dans les candidats celui qui
était plus responsable de la politique
menée par le gouvernement précédent
puisqu'en fait il était directement
responsable des deux lois les plus
impopulaires la loi qui s'appelait
l'ouham accroupi celle dont sud qui
s'est appelé le whale qu'aubry d'alois
travail mais dot hill était
l'inspirateur pour qu'il arrive et joue
celui qui arrive tout frais tout neuf
il explique je vais faire une politique
qui sera et de droite et de gauche ni de
droite ni de gauche et enfin tout
expliquer
et de droite et de droite il a une hyper
majorité il est super bien installé
emmanuel macron et il fait ce qu'il veut
notamment en économie là où justement
les français disent les sondés en tout
cas disent être le plus mécontents
ça vous surprendre encore abaissée une
vraie politique au service des riches
bon il s'est pris les pieds à pelé pris
les pieds dans le tapis avec l'histoire
de l'usf que là c'est vraiment prêt de
france mais explicitement quelque chose
qui est dédié aux riches mais à côté de
ça c'est vraiment une politique qui va
affaiblir les salariés affaiblir tous
les moyens de défense des salariés
puisque la loi la deuxième loi travail
et une loi de destruction du code du
travail qui vise vraiment à un mythe et
le code du travail
en renvoyant dans les entreprises c'est
à dire là où le chantage à l'emploi va
le plus pouvoir s'exercer contre les
salariés alors dire ah bah oui mais on
peut pas faire autrement il faut
diminuer les salaires ben oui on peut
pas faire autrement il faut travailler
plus longtemps que le concurrent tira à
m'aimer mais le concurrent a déjà fait
ça donc nous on est obligé de le faire
et on voit bien comment on va tirer tous
vers le bas yat-il fatalisme face à
emmanuel macron je pense qu'il ya pas de
fatalisme je vous l'avais dit il ya une
colère
il ya un rejet mobile pour mettre en
colère on peut ne pas être d'accord et
puis finalement laissé faire parce que
on est épuisés on ne sait pas comment
s'y prendre pour pour contrer une telle
action gouvernementale et celle du
président de la république
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a du mal à
trouver les voies et les moyens pour se
mettre tous ensemble contre ce
gouvernement parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'ils tapent sur tellement de choses à
la fois ils marchent sur l'eau emmanuel
macron et on a envie de lui retirer les
pierres qu'il a sous les pieds pour
faire semblant qui flotte sur l'eau est
ce que c'est qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
vous pouvez vous tapez a par exemple le
nouveau parti anticapitaliste ce qu'on
peut faire aujourd'hui c'est en tout cas
construire tous nos instruments de
défense nos instruments de de solidarité
bompas qui table sur tous les terrains
entre les emplois aidés
la question des apl des aides pour le
lot
on voit bien que ça c'est vraiment ce
qui touche les plus pauvres les plus les
plus fragiles les plus précaires bon
c'est pas forcément plus nombreux tout
simplement plus nombreux normalement ça
devrait être les plus nombreux dans la
rue c'est vrai pour l'instant on n'a pas
trouvé les moyens de faire que ça se
soit vraiment une force qui arrive
vraiment à bloquer macron mais en même
temps il est simple opposition une
grande contestation les deux à la fois
mais avec qui et comment
avec tous ceux qui ont des raisons de
s'opposer à la politique de maquereaux
et ils sont extrêmement nombreux c'est
vrai que dans sa façon de taper vite et
fort il ya un petit peu la volonté nous
hypnotiser nous bloquer comme ça il faut
pas se laisser prendre à ça je pense
qu'il faut se battre sur tous les
terrains chercher systématiquement
l'usiné la plus la plus large
mais pour ce bac christine poupin il
faut déjà identifié son adversaire or
c'est une autre caractéristique du
sondage paru ce matin
vos adversaires les français ne savent
même pas quoi ressemble le gouvernement
puisque les deux tiers des ministres
sont de parfaits inconnus c'est quand
même surprenant ça oui mais c'est pas
c'est moins une question de personne
qu'une question de politique puisque en
fait et malgré tout quand on regarde
dans le détail on voit un peu keith
aussi on prend le premier ministre
edouard philippe
il vient directement d'areva c'est à
dire y viennent directement du lobby du
nucléaire qui est extrêmement puissant
en france
et qu'est ce qu'on voit dans les mesures
qui sont prises par le gouvernement on
vient de repousser une mesure qui était
quand même une mesure extrêmement une
promesse tout à fait timide qui était de
réduire la part du nucléaire dans la
production d'électricité en france de la
sphère baissé de 75% à 50% en deux
harnes en 2009 35 et viennent de
repousser à 2050 puisque dans la fête
reproché à emmanuel macron son casting
heureusement qu'il peut encore choisir
les personnes qui va à vie sa politique
et son parfait pour faire sa politique
ils sont parfaits pour faire sa
politique et il ressemble tellement à
des patrons que c'est pas très difficile
de les identifier on voit bien quelle
classe ils représentent en tout cas
edouard philippe emmanuel
cros ont dit que les autres mères nos
pays doivent doivent être au centre de
la politique français politique
française qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous rencontrez vos amis du grs le
groupe révolution socialiste que que
pensez vous de cette action
gouvernementale vis-à-vis de nos pays de
la guadeloupe de la guyane de saint
martin de saint barthélémy et
dernièrement de la martinique puisqu'ils
doivent fidélité chez nous mais c'est
comme à chaque fois des paroles d effet
d'annonce on annonce comme ça des
chiffres 1 milliard pour donner
l'impression que quand on regarde ce
qu'il ya derrière on s'aperçoit que
c'était déjà de l'argent qui était prévu
mais on regroupe tout ça on met tout ça
dans une grosse boîte et puis on a l'air
d'être extrêmement généreux d'être
extrêmement intéressé alors qu'en fait
on sait bien qu'une politique contre les
plus pauvres va être une politique qui
va particulièrement s'en prendre à vie
pour les pauvres aux populations
d'ailleurs tout à fait quand vous
réduisez tous les budgets
ce nombre a baissé c'est vraiment la
politique de maquereau ou alors ceux qui
s'en fichent ce qui avait constitué les
bulletins les les
le logement social quand vous réduisez
l'argent des collectivités territoriales
qui pour beaucoup contribuer aux aides
sociales etc
quand vous supprimez les emplois aidés
ça c'est un vrai scandale c'est à dire
que c'est quelque chose qui normalement
devraient être prises par les en charge
par l'état 1,2 de l'accueil à la petite
enfance du soin aux personnes etc
l'état ne le fait plus on confie ça à
des associations
mais on leur dit mais vous allez avoir
des emplois aidés pour le faire et puis
aujourd'hui on supprime les emplois
aidés les premières victimes sont
évidemment ceux qui ont besoin de ces
services là christine poupin
il ya cent ans la révolution russe est
ce que c'est l'occasion pour vous de
discuter de discuter de cette actualité
des idées de communiste révolutionnaire
à l'heure de cette offensive du
capitalisme et de l'idéologie
néolibérale endroits sont inspirées
selon vous mais c'est très important
pour nous et et c'est un peu le sens de
notre présence ici de notre rencontre
avec nos camarades
voilà nos camarades du groupe révolution
socialiste sur cette révolution russe
pour nous ce qui est important c'est de
2 comment dire rendre la révolution
russe à celles et ceux qui louent fait
parce que la révolution russe a été
d'abord
une immense mobilisation un immense
espoir pour des millions et des millions
de personnes de paysans d'ouvriers de de
gens qui avaient été enrôlés soldats
dans cette boucherie qui était la guerre
de 14-18 monde de leur rendre leur
histoire c'est à dire leur capacité à
changer le monde
et l'idée ps le ceto six ans puisse m'en
doutais que non le stalinisme la
contre-révolution est d'ailleurs ce soir
on verra sur deux questions tout à fait
spécifique puisque on essaye aussi de
donner un panorama un petit peu complet
sur la question de l'écologie et sur la
question de la situation des femmes
comment la révolution russe a
effectivement été un changement de
société de libérateur et puis comment la
contre-révolution stalinienne a remis
pire cannes étouffoir a remis la mort
sur toutes ces aspirations ce sera ce
soir à l'impératrice merci que c'est une
probabilité se battre avec nos dents ça
aurait dit on rappelle que vous êtes
porte parole du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste bonne journée
[Musique]
les grecs